des petites pâtes
little passa
je suis français mais je sais pas
cuisiner juste les pâtes et encore moyen
bon appétit à tous
[Musique]
je n'y suis rigoureusement pour rien
j'ai le dollar mais faut pas charrier la
vérité est toute simple les dates de
travaux des transports qui amènent au
Stade de France les dates des travaux de
SNCF réseau sont connus deux ans à
l'avance et tous les professionnels de
l'événementiel le savent alors si le
producteur de Beyoncé a commis une
erreur est mis en vente des places à une
date qui était rigoureusement impossible
et intenable c'est de sa faute
je peux juste te demander un petit point
mod savoir ce que tu portes ce soir je
porte
je porte un haut noir que j'ai trouvé en
fripe ok
en collier Miou-Miou que qu'on m'a filé
pour les Anna pour l'énergie Music
Awards et une grosse veste acné et des
potes
c'est très stylé on aime beaucoup les
petites paillettes sous les yeux merci
le goût de la chose bien faite le beau
geste on ne trouve pas l'interlocuteur
en phase je dirais le miroir qui vous
aide à avancer alors ce n'est pas mon
cas comme je disais parce qu'au
contraire j'ai plus je dis merci à la
vie je dis merci je chante la vie je
danse la vie je ne suis qu'un amour et
finalement quand beaucoup de gens me
demandent comment fais-tu soutien pour
avoir cette humanité je leur réponds je
leur réponds tout simplement que c'est
ce goût de la vie ce Goudon qui m'a
poussé aujourd'hui une construction
mécanique mais qui aujourd'hui